[Música]
en directo América hablamos de salud y
por ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañera mar Romero salamar Buenos días
Buenos días Valentina empezamos en
Estados Unidos las alertas sanitarias
saltaron con cinco casos de malaria
detectados localmente parecen pocos pero
bueno Cuál es el panorama parece un poco
si realmente lo son cuando lo comparamos
con los casos de malaria que ocurren en
todo el mundo pero dan mucho que hablar
ahora lo vamos a ver aquí voy a hacer el
énfasis en tránsito localmente no porque
hay centenares de casos que se pueden
detectar en Estados Unidos que suelen
ser de personas que viajan a países
donde la malaria es endémica y se les
detecta el contagio en Estados Unidos
pero en este caso son personas que han
contraído este parásito este de la
malaria en territorio estadounidense se
detectaron cuatro casos en Florida en el
Sarasota County y en mayo junio
aproximadamente y luego un caso más
reciente en Texas la semana pasada
aunque fue esta semana que los los
centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades de estadounidenses pues
lanzaron la alerta epidemiológica para
todo el país como vemos son los regiones
que están digamos en las zonas más
templadas no más cálidas de Estados
Unidos y también más cerca a países como
México donde empieza desde México hasta
Bolivia Brasil más o menos en toda la
región americana son los países donde se
detectan malarían algunos lugares no
entonces vemos que son de los lugares
que están más cerca ahí y no se tiene
evidencia de que los casos estén
relacionados y sobre todo es lo primero
que sucede es la primera vez que sucede
desde 2003 justo hace 20 años por
supuesto se recomienda ahora que los
médicos consideren la malaria ante
personas que tengan síntomas no
solamente si estas personas tienen un
historial de viaje si no considerando
que se Podrían haber contagiado en
territorio estadounidense Bueno estamos
hablando de dos décadas dentro de
Estados Unidos sin casos de malaria Cuál
es el riesgo de que aumente esta
transmisión interna pero también en el
mundo claro por ahora digamos que en
Estados Unidos los los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades
dicen que el riesgo es bajo lo vemos en
uno de los comunicados que emitieron el
riesgo de adquirirla localmente es
extremadamente bajo hacen este énfasis
pero recuerdan que el mosquito el
anófilo que es el vector de esta
enfermedad está presente en el país no y
que si hay vector por lo tanto Hay
posibilidad de contagio Y por supuesto
que el riesgo más alto es donde las
condiciones climáticas permiten que el
mosquito viva durante la mayor parte del
año es decir los lugares como decíamos
donde las temperaturas son un poco más
altos y esto nos habla precisamente de
otra cosa que mencionabas tú también
Valentín al inicio y es el riesgo
digamos a mediano o a largo plazo quizás
estos cinco casos ahora van a quedarse
aquí pero es cierto que con el
calentamiento global va a aumentar las
zonas de Estados Unidos pero en general
de todas las regiones más temperadas
digamos del mundo donde el mosquito el
vector en la novelas puede reproducirse
haciendo que por lo tanto cada vez haya
más probabilidades de que de que se
reproduzcan o de que la se extienda
también las lluvias y las tormentas son
un factor que pueden venir a aumentar
esta transmisión de enfermedades Y como
decíamos eso Estados Unidos no está
exenta de esta posibilidad de aumento de
transmisión Pero bueno es algo que a lo
que le deberíamos estar prestando quizás
más atención de lo que hacemos pero al
final la malaria es un problema de
países tropicales todavía considerada
como una una enfermedad de países no del
primer mundo entre todas las comillas no
Al final el 95% de los casos suceden en
el continente africano entonces suele
ser una enfermedad a la que a veces pues
no se le presta tanta atención en
prevención o en investigación algo que
deberá cambiar Si queremos evitar como
decíamos que se extienda todavía más
bueno y otro de los efectos devastadores
del cambio climático Ojalá como usted lo
dice sirva para poner el foco en estos
lugares donde sí es una enfermedad
realmente grave vamos a seguir en Europa
porque hay otra enfermedad u otro
padecimiento realmente grave y es el
covid persistente la Organización
Mundial de la Salud publi las cifras de
las personas que están sufriéndolo si
ecovid persistente covid prolongado dos
palabras que se usan indistintamente
para esto que es esos síntomas cuando
los síntomas del covid se prolongan como
su nombre indica después digamos de la
infección particular por el virus se
publicaron las estimaciones no es que
sean números comprobados uno a uno sino
que son unas estimaciones de que hay 36
millones de personas en la región
europea que sufren o han sufrido este
covid prolongado en los tres años de
pandemia que llevamos no esto significa
que es un europeo de cada 30 es una
cifra verdaderamente alta que nos
Recuerda que de alguna forma la pandemia
sigue afectando la vida de muchas
personas Aunque haya dejado de ser una
emergencia internacional y de hecho
también aquí la OMS europea añadía que
todavía hay mil muertes que suceden por
Kobe 19 en Europa cada semana una cifra
nada pues bastante alta no que no
podríamos que no podemos olvidar y
recuerdan eso que para el final para
evitar el covid largo lo importante es
evitar el contagio por lo la importancia
de seguir manteniendo los esquemas de
vacunación sobre todo en las en los
grupos de más riesgo bueno el coit
persistente además todavía es una
condición incomprendida para muchos no
no sabemos de qué se trata no sabemos a
ciencia cierta Qué síntomas y qué
síntomas No qué podemos decir al
respecto sí no Y ese es uno de los
grandes problemas de esta enfermedad
porque si no sabes cómo definirla no
sabes bien cómo medirla tampoco o qué
hacer para prevenirla y por eso el
director de la OMS en Europa pedía más
investigaciones escuchémoslo
low cover tremens a glading Blind spot
el covid persistente sigue siendo un
punto ciego de nuestro conocimiento que
necesita aclararse rápidamente
si no desarrollamos diagnósticos y
tratamientos para el covid persistente
nunca nos recuperaremos verdaderamente
de la pandemia
pedimos más investigación e instamos a
quienes puedan vacunarse que se vacunen
esta condición invisible debería tomarse
en serio En todos los sectores sociales
y de salud
claro este punto ciego del que habla
Hans que también estaba mencionando no
sucede que no hay un consenso sobre la
definición de este covid persistente hay
personas que hablan de que les cambia el
olfato o el gusto durante unos pocos
meses Pero hay personas que tres años
después todavía pierden el aliento
cuando intentan hacer deporte o cuando
intentan subir las escaleras no sabemos
si poner eso dentro de la misma bolsa o
no y eso ha hecho esta falta de
definición o de consenso ha hecho que
también proliferen muchos estudios con
muy poca consistencia no muy flojos hace
que sea muy difícil estudiar la
prevalencia de nuevo de esta enfermedad
Cuántas personas la están sufriendo
Cuántas no y por supuesto también hace
que sea muy difícil definir estrategias
sobre cómo tratarlo No sobre qué hacer
al respecto Entonces en este caso en el
caso europeo no sabemos cómo se han
hecho las estimaciones pero
definitivamente sabemos que puede estar
afectando a muchas personas y
necesitamos tener un poco más de
claridades y por eso más investigación
sobre sobre cómo definirlo sobre qué se
trata y sobre qué hacer al respecto
cuando una persona lo desarrolla bueno y
por lo menos hasta el momento seguir con
el esquema de vacunación y seguir con
esta lavado de manos con todas estas
medidas que deberían estar apropiadas y
en muchos casos No sí pequeñas medidas
de prevención que ya sabemos que todo el
mundo tiene mucha prisa para dejar este
problema del covid atrás pero que hoy en
día pues nos podrían todavía ayudar
a limitar un poco estas Consecuencias
negativas mar Muchas gracias por toda
esta ampliación nos vemos mañana hasta
mañana Valentina